(Rires)
Elle avait anticipé que l'Amérique se tourne vers le nativisme.
C'était une futuriste noire.
(Rires)
Thurston est un nom britannique, mais nous ne sommes pas Britanniques.
Dédicace à l'institution économique multigénérationnelle et déshumanisante
de l'esclavage de Noirs en Amérique.
Thurston est également un super nom pour Starbucks.
Cela accélère le processus.
(Rires)
Ma mère était une femme de la Renaissance.
Arnita Lorraine Thurston
était programmeuse informatique, ancienne employée de maison,
survivante d'une agression sexuelle,
une artiste et une activiste.
Elle m'a préparé à ce monde avec des leçons sur l'histoire noire,
des arts martiaux, de l'agriculture urbaine
puis elle m'a envoyé en 5ème à l'école privée de Sidwell Friends,
où les présidents américains envoient leurs filles
et elle m'y a envoyé ainsi.
(Rires)
J'avais deux missions-clés au sein de cette école :
ne perds pas ta noirceur et ne perds pas tes lunettes.
J'ai ainsi accompli les deux.
(Rires)
Sidwell était un super endroit pour apprendre les arts et les sciences,
mais aussi l'art de vivre au milieu de la blancheur.
Cela m'a préparé à une vie future à Harvard,
à faire du conseil aux entreprises
ou travailler à « The Daily Show » et « The Onion ».
Je pourrais écrire de nombreuses leçons dans mon mémoire, « Comment être noir »,
si vous ne l'avez pas encore lu, cela fait de vous un raciste --
(Rires)
car vous aviez plein de temps pour lire le livre.
Mais l'Amérique insiste pour me rappeler
et m'enseigner
ce que c'est d'être noir en Amérique.
Nous sommes en décembre 2018,
je suis avec ma fiancée dans une banlieue du Wisconsin.
Nous rendons visite à ses parents, qui sont tous deux blancs,
elle est donc blanche.
Ça marche comme ça. Je n'ai pas décidé des règles.
(Rires)
Elle a bu quelques verres, alors je conduis la voiture de ses parents
et la police nous fait signe de nous arrêter.
J'ai peur.
J'allume mon clignotant pour indiquer que j'obtempère,
je me range doucement
sous le lampadaire le plus lumineux que je trouve
au cas où j'ai besoin de témoins ou de la vidéo de la caméra embarquée.
Nous sortons mon permis, la carte grise de la voiture,
les plaçons de façon visible, descendons les vitres,
mes mains sont sur le volant,
tout cela avant que l'officière ne sorte de son véhicule.
Voilà comment rester en vie.
Alors que nous attendons, je pense à ces gros titres,
« La police tire sur une autre personne noire non armée »,
et je ne veux pas me joindre à elles.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que notre officière était sympathique.
Elle nous a dit que l'immatriculation avait expiré.
A tous les parents blancs,
si votre enfant sort avec quelqu'un
dont la couleur de peau est aussi foncée que Dwayne « The Rock » Johnson --
(Rires)
vous devez faire inspecter la voiture, mettre à jour les papiers à chaque visite.
C'est de la simple courtoisie.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J'ai eu de la chance.
J'ai eu à faire à une professionnelle des forces de l'ordre.
J'ai survécu à quelque chose
qui ne devrait pas nécessiter qu'on y survive.
Je pense à cette série d'histoires --
« La police tire sur une autre personne noire non armée » --
et la saison où ces histoires ont fait leur apparition partout.
Je faisais défiler mon fil d'actualités
et je voyais un faire-part de naissance.
Je voyais une pub pour un produit
au sujet duquel j'avais chuchoté avec un ami la veille.
Je voyais une vidéo d'un officier de police
descendant quelqu'un qui me ressembait.
Je voyais un article de fond
sur comment la génération Y avait remplacé le sexe par des toasts à l'avocat.
(Rires)
C'était une période déroutante.
Ces histoires continuaient de surgir,
mais en 2018, ces histoires ont été remplacées par un autre type d'histoires :
« Une femme blanche appelle la police
au sujet d'une femme noire attendant un Uber ».
C'était Betty de Brooklyn.
« Une femme blanche appelle la police
au sujet d'une Noire de huit ans vendant de l'eau ».
C'était Patty et son permis.
Puis : « Une femme appelle la police
au sujet d'une famille noire faisant un barbecue ».
C'était la maintenant célèbre Becky et son barbecue.
Je soutiens que ces histoires de la vie en tant que Noir
sont une marque de progrès.
Avant, nous découvrions cela après les homicides policiers extrajudiciaires.
Maintenant, nous avons des vidéos de gens appelant la police.
Nous remontons le courant,
nous nous rapprochons du problème et de la solution.
Alors j'ai démarré une collection
de toutes les histoires que je pouvais trouver.
J'ai créé une base de données évolutive et en pleine expansion
sur baratunde.com/livingwhileblack.
En cherchant à comprendre, j'ai réalisé que le processus
était de faire un diagramme de ces phrases pour comprendre ces gros titres.
Je veux remercier mon enseignante d'anglais de Sidwell, Erica Berry,
et tous mes enseignants d'anglais.
Vous m'avez donné les outils pour me battre pour notre liberté.
Ce que j'ai découvert était une méthode pour décomposer le titre
et comprendre les couches logiques
dans chacun d'eux :
un sujet agit contre une cible exerçant une activité.
« Une femme blanche appelle la police au sujet d'une fille noire de huit ans »
est identique à « Un homme blanc appelle la police
au sujet d'une femme noire utilisant la piscine »,
est identique à « Une femme blanche appelle la police
au sujet d'un législateur noir de l'Oregon faisant campagne dans son district ».
C'est la même chose.
Faire un diagramme de ces phrases m'a permis de faire un diagramme
de la suprématie blanche
qui a permis à ces phrases d'être vraies
et je vais marquer une pause pour définir mes termes.
Quand je dis « suprématie blanche »,
je ne parle pas que des nazis
ou des activistes du pouvoir blanc
et je ne dis certainement pas que tous les Blancs sont racistes.
Ce à quoi je fais référence,
c'est à un système d'avantages structurels favorisant les Blancs plus que les autres
dans les arènes sociales, économiques et politiques.
C'est ce que Bryan Stevenson
de l'initiative pour une justice égalitaire
appelle le récit de la différence raciale,
l'histoire que nous nous sommes racontée pour justifier l'esclavage, Jim Crow,
l'incarcération de masse et d'autres.
Quand j'ai vu cette structure se répéter,
cela m'a mis en colère
mais cela m'a aussi inspiré
à créer un jeu,
un jeu de mots qui me permettrait
de transformer cette exposition traumatique
en une expérience thérapeutique.
Je vais vous expliquer le jeu.
Le premier niveau est un niveau d'entraînement
et j'ai besoin de votre participation.
Notre objectif : déterminer si ceci est vrai ou faux.
Ceci est-il arrivé ?
Voici l'exemple :
« Un bibliothécaire d'une fac de droit catholique
appelle la police au sujet d'un étudiant trop “ argumentatif ” ».
Tapez des mains si vous pensez que c'est vrai.
(Applaudissements)
Tapes des mains si vous pensez que c'est faux.
Ceux pensant que c'est vrai ont malheureusement raison,
et un point d'information :
être argumentatif dans une bibliothèque de droit,
c'est le bon endroit.
(Rires)
Cet étudiant devrait être promu professeur.
Niveau d'entraînement terminé, nous passons aux vrais niveaux.
Niveau un, notre objectif est simple :
inverser les rôles.
« Une femme appelle la police au sujet d'un législateur noir »
devient « Un législateur noir appelle la police au sujet d'une femme ».
« Un homme blanc appelle la police au sujet d'une femme noire
utilisant la piscine »
devient « Une femme noire appelle la police
au sujet d'un homme blanc utilisant la piscine ».
Est-ce que vous aimez quand c'est inversé ?
Ça y est, niveau terminé
et nous passons au niveau deux
où notre objectif est d'augmenter la crédibilité de l'inversion.
Une femme noire appelant la police au sujet d'un homme blanc dans une piscine
n'est pas assez absurde,
mais et si cet homme blanc essayait de toucher ses cheveux sans demander,
qu'il faisait du lait d'avoine en faisant du monocycle
ou qu'il coupait la parole à tout le monde durant une réunion.
(Rires)
Nous avons tous connu cela, n'est-ce pas ?
Sérieusement, nous avons tous connu cela.
Ça y est, niveau deux terminé.
Mais il s'accompagne d'un avertissement :
se contenter d'inverser l'injustice n'est pas de la justice.
C'est de la vengeance, ce n'est pas notre mission,
c'est un jeu différent, alors nous passons au niveau trois
où l'objectif est de changer l'action,
ou « appeler la policer n'est pas votre seule option,
c'est quoi votre problème à tous ?! »
(Applaudissements)
Je dois mettre le jeu en pause pour nous rappeler la structure.
Un sujet agit contre une cible exerçant une activité.
« Une Blanche appelle la police au sujet d'un investisseur immobilier noir
inspectant sa propre propriété ».
« Un supermarché appelle la police au sujet d'une femme noire
donnant à manger aux sans-abris ».
« Un club de golf appelle la police
au sujet de femmes noires jouant trop lentement ».
Dans tous ces cas, le sujet est généralement blanc,
la cible est généralement noire
et les activités sont variées,
de s'asseoir à un Starbucks
à utiliser le mauvais type de barbecue,
en passant par faire une sieste
et marcher jusqu'au travail de façon « agitée »,
ce que j'appelle « aller au travail ».
(Rires)
Et mon préféré,
ne pas empêcher son chien de sauter le sien,
ce qui est clairement une affaire pour la police canine,
pas pour la police humaine.
Toutes ces activités reviennent à vivre.
Notre existence est interprétée comme un crime.
C'est le moment obligatoire dans la présentation où je dois dire
qu'il n'est pas toujours question de race.
Les crimes existent, ils devraient être signalés,
mais demandez-vous si nous avons besoin
que des hommes armés viennent pour régler cette situation,
car quand ils viennent pour moi,
c'est différent.
Nous savons que les officiers de police
ont plus recours à la force
avec des gens noirs qu'avec des gens blancs
et nous découvrons le rôle des appels à la police dans tout cela.
Grâce des recherches préliminaires du centre pour l'équité policière,
nous apprenons qu'il y a des villes
où la plupart des interactions entre la police et les citoyens
sont dues à des appels à la police,
à des arrestations non initiées par la police
et pour la plupart de la violence,
le recours à la force par la police sur les citoyens
est en réponse à ces appels.
De plus, quand ces officiers qui répondent aux appels ont recours à la force,
cela est accru dans les zones
où le pourcentage de Blancs dans la population
est également accru,
soit de la gentrification,
soit des monocycles et du lait d'avoine,
soit quand la Becky du barbecue se sent menacée,
elle devient une menace pour moi dans mon propre quartier,
ce qui nous force, moi et les gens comme moi,
à nous contenir.
Nous devenons plus calmes, nous marchons sur des œufs,
peut-être que nous nous rangeons
sous la lumière la plus lumineuse possible
afin que notre meurtre
puisse être filmé clairement
et nous faisons cela car nous vivons dans un système
où les gens blancs peuvent trop facilement appeler des forces mortelles
pour assurer leur confort.
(Applaudissements)
Le supermarché
ne s'est pas contenté d'appeler la police
au sujet d'une femme donnant à manger aux sans-abris.
Il a commandé des hommes armés, sans compte à rendre.
Il a appelé à une frappe de drone.
Le malaise est devenu une arme
et ce n'est pas nouveau.
De 1877 à 1950,
il y a eu au moins 4 400 lynchages de terreur raciale documentés
envers des personnes noires aux États-Unis.
Ils ont également fait les gros titres.
« Le révérend T.A. Allen a été lynché à Hernando, Mississippi,
pour avoir organisé les métayers locaux ».
« Oliver Moore a été lynché dans le comté d'Edgecombe
pour avoir effrayé une fille blanche ».
« Nathan Bird a été lynché au Texas
pour avoir refusé de livrer son fils à la pègre ».
Nous devons changer l'action,
que cette action soit « lynche »
ou « appelle la police ».
Maintenant que j'ai réduit la distance entre les deux,
revenons-en à notre jeu, à notre mission.
Notre objectif qu niveau trois est de changer l'action.
Et si au lieu de
« Appelle la police au sujet d'une femme donnant à manger aux sans-abris »,
ce supermarché se contentait de la remercier ?
Remercier coûte bien moins cher que d'appeler les forces de l'ordre.
(Applaudissements)
Ou au lieu de cela,
ils pourraient lui donner la nourriture qu'ils auraient jetée,
accroître leur engagement civique.
Ou la femme blanche qui a appelé la police au sujet de la fille noire de huit ans
aurait pu acheter tous les stocks de cette petite fille noire,
soutenir une petite affaire.
Et la femme blanche qui a appelé la police au sujet de l'investisseur noir,
la police s'accorde à dire que nous irions mieux
si elle l'avait simplement ignoré et s'était occupée de ses affaires.
(Rires)
S'occuper de ses affaires est un choix excellent, excellent.
Choisissez de le faire plus souvent.
Le niveau trois est terminé, mais il y a un niveau final bonus
où l'objectif est l'inclusion.
Nous avons tous vu de tels titres :
« Un homme puissant se masturbe devant de jeunes femmes
visitant son bureau ».
Quel choix bizarre à faire pour un homme puissant.
Il y avait tant d'autres actions possibles.
(Rires)
Comme « écoute »,
« encadre »,
« inspiré par, s'associe à, tout le monde est maintenant riche ».
(Rires)
Je veux vivre dans ce monde où tout le monde est riche
mais, à cause de son mauvais choix,
nous vivons tous dans un monde plus mauvais.
Cela n'a pas à être ainsi.
Ce jeu de mots m'a rappelé qu'il y a une structure dans la suprématie blanche,
comme dans la misogynie,
comme dans tout abus de pouvoir systémique.
La structure le rend systémique.
Je demande aux gens ici
de voir la structure,
où le pouvoir est au sein de la structure
et, surtout, de voir l'humanité
chez ceux d'entre nous pris pour cibles par cette structure.
Je suis ici car j'ai été aimé, qu'on a investi en moi,
que j'ai été protégé et chanceux,
que j'ai été aux bonnes écoles, je suis un peu connu, plutôt heureux,
que je médite deux fois par jour
et pourtant,
je vis dans la peur
car je sais que quelqu'un me percevant comme étant une menace
peut devenir une menace pour ma vie
et je suis fatigué.
J'en ai marre de porter
ce poids invisible de la peur des autres,
beaucoup d'entre nous le portent
et nous ne devrions pas avoir à le faire
car nous pouvons changer cela,
nous pouvons changer l'action, qui change l'histoire,
qui change le système
qui permet à ces histoires de se dérouler.
Les systèmes ne sont que des histoires collectives auxquelles nous adhérons tous.
Quand nous les changeons,
nous écrivons une meilleure réalité à laquelle nous pouvons tous prendre part.
Je vous demande
de faire usage de votre pouvoir de décision.
Je vous demande de passer au niveau suivant.
Merci.
Je suis Baratunde Rafiq Thurston.
(Applaudissements)